determina el dominio de fx igual a raíz
de 2x menos 8 y acordándonos el dominio
es simplemente el conjunto de valores
para los cuales tiene sentido evaluar la
función f o también podemos decirlo así
podemos decir que es el conjunto de
valores en donde la función f está
definida y aquí para que la función f
esté definida debemos de asegurarnos de
sacar la raíz cuadrada de un número
mayor o igual que 0 entonces debemos
pedir que 2x menos 8 2x menos 8 sea
mayor o igual que 0 si 2 x menos 80 no
hay problema raíz de 0 es cero si es
positivo tampoco hay problema pero si 2x
menos 8 fuera negativo entonces
estaríamos sacando la raíz cuadrada de
un número negativo y eso no sabemos
resolverlo en los números reales
entonces necesitamos pedir que 2x menos
8 sea mayor o igual que 0 y a partir de
aquí podemos pues resolver esta
desigualdad despejando a x cómo le
hacemos podemos sumar 8 de ambos lados
de la desigualdad
2x es mayor o igual que menos 88 aquí ya
no ponemos nada 0 8 nos queda aquí 8 y
ahora podemos dividir a ambos lados de
la desigualdad entre dos como 2 es un
número positivo entonces no cambia la
desigualdad y nos queda que x debe de
ser mayor o igual que 4 muy bien
entonces esto de aquí ya es una
expresión para el dominio deja lo pongo
por acá el dominio el dominio
entonces el dominio de la función es
todos aquellos números reales que sean
mayores o iguales que 4 o bien otra
forma de decirlo es que la función f
está definida para cuando x es mayor o
igual que 4